in this video we'll talk about neural
tube defects
our neural tube is a primordium of the
brain and spinal cord that means our
brain and spinal cord our entire central
nervous system is actually derived from
this embryonic structure which is known
as neural tube
at a morphological level brain and
spinal cord is nothing but a tube with a
variable diameter at its different ends
so we can imagine brain and spinal
column to be a tube
so let's try to understand how neural
tube closure and defect in this closure
can lead to several
brain disorders
so the two most common form of neural
tube defects are
spina bifida that means it has a
defect in the spinal cord
and it happens when the posterior end of
the neural tube or the cordal end of the
neural tube doesn't close properly
and the second type is anencephaly which
is a brain defect and it happens when
the anterior portion or the
cranial half of the neural tube does not
close properly these are the two most
common
neural tube defects there are many
others which we would look at and review
in this video
let's talk about the risk factors
which can lead to neural tube defects
risk factors includes nutritional status
especially folic acid deficiency and
vitamin b12 deficiency can lead to
neural tube defects
exposure to environmental toxicants
stressors
and clinical situations like obesity and
diabetes could accelerate the process of
neural tube defects in pregnant women
genetic
disposition is another important factor
which might be a causal for neural tube
defect
now the biggest
factor about neural tube defect is its
diagnosis
first of all the interneural tube
closure happens within the first month
of the pregnancy
by this time the woman might not know
that she is pregnant
and in this particular time window
folate is really essential and in this
particular time window of one month if
folate is not present in an adequate
amount in the diet
then it might lead to a neural tube
defect
that is why whenever a woman is thinking
of conceiving
at that very moment they should start
taking uh folic acid supplements at
least 400 microgram of folic acid daily
till the 12 week of gestation and that
is really important
and this kind of dietary awareness is
not present in the third world countries
that is why the incidence of neural tube
defects is more in the
third world countries compared to the
developed countries that means in africa
india these kind of defects are more
common than in u.s and any other first
world countries
let's talk about the classification of
neural tube defects
so this is a
typical neural tube
and this is the cranial in that means
this particular portion would eventually
form the brain and the other end is the
caudal end
this is the endpoint of the spinal cord
now if the cranial end failed to fuse
and close then there are defects like
anencephaly where the baby is born
without the part of its entire brain or
skull this is a severe form of defect
and the baby does not survive
eventually
there is also encephali that means a
extreme retroflexion of the head the
head is bent backwards this is also a
kind of defect
here the baby is born might survive for
a few years but eventually the survival
chance is really low
then there is
encephalocele
encephalocele is a sac like protrusion
projecting out of the brain of the
newborn and this is kind of like a
membranous cover
sometimes some in some extreme cases the
cover might be absent as well so these
are the defects which happens when the
cranial end
failed to fuse
now what happens when the caudal end
closure doesn't happen
so before that let me tell you there is
an extreme form of neural tube
closure defect which is very hard to
pronounce
but in
the craniosp of brain and cranial vault
is visible so the entire brain and the
spinal column is kind of missing
and if the caudal end doesn't fuse
properly there could be spina bifida
and there is open spina bifida or there
could be closed spina bifida
so in this kind of disease
a section of the spinal cord and the
spinal nerve get exposed through a
opening in the back and it kind of bulge
outside
now let us try to understand the
mechanism of this disease and try to
understand the neural tube closure in
bit more details
so in order to understand neural tube
closure we have to imagine a sheet like
this
and we want to make a tube out of this
sheet so we have to fold this
and ultimately we can fold it into a
tube right
exactly same thing is happening while
our nervous system is developing in the
mother's womb
so this is how
the
initial embryo look like here the yellow
portion is the neuro ectoderm that would
eventually form
the brain and the entire nervous system
this particular structure eventually
folds
and there is one cranial end forms and
another coral end is formed in this
particular structure so asymmetry is
evoked
the cranial end would ultimately become
the head
and the caudal end would be
the in portion of the spinal cord
now this particular neural tube has to
fold this this has to curl and fold to
complete this tube like formation
by day 21
this folding process is peaking and the
particular folding is happening in the
midline
then at day 24 the middle portion of
this neural tube is already folded
so the middle portion is fused together
the cranial
and the caudal ends are not fused yet
so the cranial part there is cranial
neuropore and in the caudal part there
is caudal neuropore
this has to be closed in subsequent days
by day 26 to 28
both these openings has to be closed
entirely
so just to recap what we have learned so
far this is the top view of the embryo
where we can see the neural ectoderm and
how the neural ectoderm is actually
dipping inside and forming a neural tube
and the neural tube closure is done by
the day 28 of
the gestation life
so at day 28 everything should be fused
if it doesn't fuse and especially in if
the
cranial end doesn't fuse it might lead
to an anencephaly if the caudal end
doesn't fuse it might lead to spina
bifida as we have mentioned earlier
let's look at the spina bifida in bit
more details
so let's talk about the subtypes of
spina bifida
so this is how a normal spinal column
and the end of the spinal column look
like there would be vertebral body
and this is the spinal cord visualized
in gray and the meninges is actually in
pink
and here we can see the spinal processes
so there are different types of spina
bifida which has different severity
the less severe form is spinal bifida
okulta
so this is the mildest and the most
common form
generally this form
leads to one or more vertebra missing in
the spinal column or they are malformed
most of the cases the spinal processes
are malformed
anyway oculus means hidden that means
this kind of defects does not express
its
itself that means it's not really
diagnosed during screening procedures
and also it doesn't show a lot of like
consequences in the later personal life
and very rarely it cause any kind of
disabilities so it's the most
mildest form of spina bifida
next form is
meningocele in meningocele
the spinal fluid pokes through the spine
and it pokes out of the back of the baby
and forms a bulge
notice that
the
spinal column on the spinal nerves
are
intact and they are not protruded
and the nerves may or may not be covered
by a layer of skin
now in these cases
there might be minor symptoms
and that symptom can be treatable
the most extreme situation is known as
myelomeningocele
in this case
what happens is
um
the
entire portion of the spinal cord
and the nerves and also
the meninges
totally protrudes out of the back
majority of the cases it is covered by
the skin and some extreme cases the skin
might not be present
so it lead to severe situation often it
increases the chance of infections
by bacteria so it can cause meningitis
and many other infection because the
nerves are exposed it could be pretty
detrimental and especially babies with
myelomalingosis develops many problems
including including the renal blood
problems
let's talk about the diagnosis of
this kind of neural tube defects the
major way of diagnosing neural tube
defect is basically doing a ultrasound
if there is a huge defect or a major
defect like myelomalingon or meningocele
then it can be detected easily with a
high resolution ultrasound
other than that there could be
biomarkers which can be detected in
mother's blood or mother's serum such as
alpha fetal protein which should not be
leaked out in the mother's blood but a
high level of alpha phetoprotein could
be indicative of some kind of birth
defect most of the cases
it is due to
neural tube closure defects
also the amniotic fluid can be analyzed
for the level of
alpha phytoprotein as well as the level
of
acetylcholinesterase
all of these things should be in a very
low level in the amniotic fluid in case
of neural tube defects everything leaks
into the amniotic fluid and their level
goes up
now let's talk about the genetic
disposition that leads to this kind of
neural tube fold neural tube closure
defects
it turns out
studying these kind of neural tube
defect is really difficult because at
that point of gestation it's impossible
to study a human subject so whatever we
know from a genetic point of view comes
from our study in mouse and other
clinical models
it turns out that there are specific
signaling pathway
whose alteration can lead to this kind
of neural tube defect and one
significant pathway is wind pcp or
planar cell polarity pathway defect in
wind pcp pathway molecules can
ultimately lead to neural tube closure
defects
let's talk about the treatment options
there could be prenatal surgery
but it has a very high risk
there could be postnatal surgery that
means the surgery happens
after the baby is born
in this case surgically the
portion of the back is closed
and due to and the defective neural tube
is actually taken inside
but i mean it would reduce the risk of
meningitis and many other bacterial
infection but it cannot heal the
defect
so there is no absolute treatment for
these kind of defects
but there are supportive treatments that
can make the situation better can
increase the life expectancy
in summary we have learned about the
types of neural tube defects
we looked at the risk factors that might
lead to neural tube defects
we looked at the diagnosis of neural
tube defect and lastly we explored the
treatment options of neural tube defect
i hope this video was informative enough
if you like this video give it a quick
thumbs up don't forget to subscribe and
hit that bell icon for notification you
can support my channel by clicking on
this
payment button by clicking on this you
have payment option you can support my
channel by contributing a very small
amount and that means a lot to me
you can get lot of notes flashcards in
my facebook page and also in my
instagram page like these ones
so do check that out links are in the
description as usual don't forget to
like share and subscribe you can take my
courses in an academy which is india's
biggest online learning platform using a
code ap 10 you can get a 10 discount if
you wish to connect feel free to connect
by